Das Brandenburger Tor:
Berlins wichtigstes Wahrzeichen
im Zentrum der deutschen Hauptstadt.
Ein rund 20 Meter hohes Bauwerk mit
zwei Torflügeln an seinen Seiten –
der krönende Abschluss der Prachtstraße
„Unter den Linden“.
Ein Triumph-Tor, das sich Preußenkönig
Friedrich Wilhelm II.
Ende des 18. Jahrhunderts bauen ließ.
Gekrönt wird es von einer sechs Meter
hohen Quadriga.
Die vier Pferde werden von der römischen
Siegesgöttin Victoria gelenkt.
Zuerst war sie nackt,
ein Gewand bekam sie später.
Die Historikerin Zitha Pöthe-Elevi hat die
Botschaft des Bauwerks entschlüsselt.
1788 kommt es zu einem
wichtigen Ereignis in Preußen:
Friedrich Wilhelm II.
kann ein für ihn sehr wichtiges Bündnis
schließen mit Großbritannien und der
Republik der Niederlande.
Das möchte er gebührend feiern und
baut sich hier ein Triumph-Tor.
Der Entwurf aus Sandstein im
frühklassizistischen Stil stammt von
Carl Gotthard Langhans – nach dem Vorbild
des Eingangstors zur Akropolis in Athen.
Für die Quadriga und viele andere
Ausschmückungen war der Bildhauer
Johann Gottfried Schadow zuständig.
Zitha Pöthe-Elevi hat ein Buch über das
Brandenburger Tor geschrieben
und erklärt den Unterschied zum
griechischen Vorbild.
Friedrich Wilhelm bat seinen Architekten
Langhans darum, möglichst viel Öffnung
des Brandenburger Tores zu ermöglichen,
sodass die Durchsicht natürlich
auf den Tiergarten und diese lange
Achse Richtung Westen
mit diesem westlichen Horizont [geht].
Das sieht man sehr schön:
Hier sehen wir auf dem Bild zum Beispiel
dieses sehr Enge, etwas Gedrungene
der Architektur, der griechischen
Marmorarchitektur,
während wir diese schöne
Zentralperspektive entwickeln konnten.
Das Brandenburger Tor zieht jeden Tag
Besucher aus aller Welt an.
Die Pracht des Gebäudes, seine Höhe
und die Figuren an den Säulen,
das ist wirklich spektakulär.
Ich fühle mich vor diesem
massiven Tor sehr klein.
Ich bin zum ersten Mal in Europa und habe
so etwas Großartiges noch nie gesehen.
Jahrzehntelang war das Brandenburger Tor
vor allem Symbol der deutschen Teilung –
isoliert im Sperrgebiet zwischen dem Ost-
und dem Westteil Berlins.
Erst nach dem Mauerfall wurde es 1989
wieder für alle zugänglich.
Jetzt ist es Symbol der deutschen Einheit.
Ich denke, dadurch, dass es so lange Zeit
die Grenze markiert hat
zwischen den beiden Blöcken
Ost und West,
hat sich hier eine ganz, ganz besondere
emotionale Schranke auch gebildet.
Die ist dann ja mit dem Eisernen Vorhang
am 22.12. hier auch gefallen –
einer der letzten Grenzübergänge, den die
SED-Führung freigegeben hat.
Wer nach all diesen Eindrücken
einen Moment der Besinnung braucht,
kann hierherkommen:
in den "Raum der Stille"
im angrenzenden Torhaus.
Diese Stille da drinnen ist sehr
faszinierend und beruhigend.
Im Gegensatz zu hier draußen, wo der
ganze Tumult ist, kommt man darinnen
wieder zur Ruhe und findet man
seine innere Mitte.
Das Brandenburger Tor fasziniert auch die
Euromaxx-Zuschauer,
die ihre Aufnahmen geschickt haben.
Wer das Brandenburger Tor nach
Hause mitnehmen möchte,
kann sich in einem der Souvenirshops
eine Mini-Ausgabe kaufen.
Als Erinnerung an einen ganz besonderen Ort.